[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Good evening and welcome to the Sony Center for Performing Arts.
Please note during tonight's presentation,
video,
audio and flash photography is prohibited and we have a strict zero tolerance
policy for any heckling or disruptions.
[inaudible]
and now,
please welcome your host and moderator,
President of Ralston College,
Dr Steven Blackwood.
[inaudible].
Thank you.
A warm welcome to all of you here this evening.
Both of those here in the feed or in Toronto and those following online.
You know,
it's not very often that you see a country's largest theater packed for an
intellectual debate,
but that's what we're all here for tonight.
Please join me
[inaudible]
please join me in welcoming to the stage Dr Slab was Gtech and Dr. Jordan
Peterson.
[inaudible]
just a few words of introduction.
There can be huge things I think now more urgent and necessary in an age of
reactionary partisan allegiance and degraded civil discourse.
Then real thinking about hard questions.
The very premise of tonight's event is that we all participate in the life of
thought,
not merely opinion or prejudice,
but the realm of truth,
access through evidence and argument.
But these two towering figures of different disciplines and domains share more
than a commitment to thinking itself.
They are both highly attuned to etiology and the mechanisms of power,
and yet they are not principally political thinkers.
They are both concerned with more fundamental matters,
meaning truth freedom.
So it seems to me likely we will see tonight not only deep differences,
but also surprising agreement on deep questions.
Doctor [inaudible] is a philosopher.
He has not one but two doctoral degrees,
one in philosophy
[inaudible]
what in philosophy from the University of Lube,
Leanna and a second in psychoanalysis from university
[inaudible].
Let's hear it for cycle analysis
for the University of Paris eight he is now a professor at the Institute of
Sociology and Philosophy at the University of Louisiana and the director of the
Berbick Institute for the humanities at the University of London.
He has published more than three dozen,
many on the most seminal philosophers of the 19th and 20th centuries.
He is a dazzling theorist with extraordinary range,
a global figure for decades.
He turns again and again with dialectical power to radical questions of
emancipation,
subjectivity and art.
[inaudible],
Dr. Jordan Peterson is an academic
and political [inaudible],
an academic and clinical psychologist.
His doctorate was awarded by Mcgill University and he was subsequently,
we've got some new go gap graduates out here.
He was subsequently professor of psychology at Harvard University and then the
University of Toronto where he is today.
[inaudible]
the author of two books in well over a hundred academic articles.
Dr Peterson's intellectual roots likewise lie in the 19th and early 20th
centuries where his reading of Nicha Dostoyevsky and above all,
Carl EWM inform his interpretation of ancient myths of 20th century
totalitarianism and especially his endeavor to counter contemporary nihilism.
His 12 rules for life is a global best seller and his lectures and podcasts are
followed by millions around the world.
[inaudible].
Both
doctors Jijak and Peterson transcend their titles,
their disciplines,
and the academy.
Just as this debate,
we hope will transcend purely economic questions by situating those in the frame
of happiness of human flourishing itself.
We're in for quite a night,
a quick word about format.
Each of our debaters will have 30 minutes to make a substantial opening
statement to lay out an argument.
Dr. Peterson first followed by Doctor Jijak each.
We'll then have in the same order,
10 minutes to reply.
I will then moderate 45 minutes or so of questions,
many of which will come from the audience,
both here in Toronto and online.
With that,
let's get underway.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Jordan Peterson for the first opening
statement.
[inaudible]
well thank you for that insanely enthusiastic welcome for the entire event and
also for being here.
I have to tell you first,
um,
that this event and I suppose my life in some sense hit a new milestone that I
was just made aware of by a stage hand today backstage who informed me that last
week the tickets for this event,
we're being scalped online at a higher price than the tickets for the leafs
playoff games.
[inaudible]
so,
uh,
I don't know what to make of that.
That's all right.
So how did I prepare for this?
Um,
I went,
I familiarized myself to the degree that it was possible with Slava was GCX work
and that wasn't that possible because he has a lot of work and he's a very
original thinker.
And this debate was put together in relatively short order.
And what I did instead was returned to what I regarded as the original cause of
all the trouble,
let's say,
which was the communist manifesto.
And what I attempted to do because that's marks and we're here to talk about
Marxism.
Let's see.
And um,
what I tried to do was read it and to read something.
You don't just
follow the words and follow the meaning,
but you take apart the sentences and you ask yourself at this level of phrase
and that the level of sentences in it,
the level of paragraph,
is this true?
Are there counter arguments that can be put forward that are credible?
Is this solid thinking?
And I have to tell you,
and I'm not trying to be flippant here,
that I have rarely read a track.
Now I read it when I was 18.
It was a long time ago,
right?
That's 40 years ago.
But I've rarely read a track that made as many errors per sentence,
conceptual errors percent and says the communist manifesto.
It was quite a miraculous.
Reread it.
And it was interesting to think about it psychologically as well because I've
read student papers that were of the same ilk in some sense,
although I'm not suggesting that they were of the same level of glittering
literary brilliance and polemic quality.
And I also understand that the communist manifesto was a call for revolution and
not a standard logical argument,
but that not withstanding,
I have some things say about the author's psychologically.
The first thing is that it doesn't seem to me that either Mark's or ingles
grappled with one fundamental with this particular fundamental truth,
which is that almost all ideas are wrong.
And so if you,
and it doesn't matter if they're your ideas or someone else's ideas,
they're probably wrong.
And even if they strike you with the force of brilliance,
you're job is to assume first of all,
that they're probably wrong.
And then to assault them with everything you have in your arsenal and see if
they can survive.
And what,
what struck me about the communist manifesto was it was akin to something young
said about typical thinking.
And this was the thinking of people who weren't trained to think.
And he said that the typical thinker has a thought,
it appears to them like an object might appear in a room the thought appears and
then they just,
they just accepted as true.
They don't go to second step,
which is to think about the thinking.
And that's the real essence of critical thinking.
And so that's what you try to teach people in university is to read a text and
to think about it critically,
not to destroy the utility of the text,
but to separate the wheat from the chaff.
And so what I tried to do when I was reading the communist manifesto was to
separate the wheat from the chaff.
And I'm afraid I found some wheat,
yes,
but most of the chaff.
And I'm going to explain why,
um,
hopefully,
uh,
in relatively short order.
So I'm going to outline 10 of the fundamental axioms of the communist manifesto.
And so these are truths that are basically held as self evident by the authors
and their truths that are presented in some sense as unquestioned.
And I'm going to question them and tell you why I think they're,
um,
unreliable.
Now we should remember that this tract was actually written 170 years ago.
That's a long time ago.
And we have learned a fair bit from since then about human nature,
about society,
about politics,
about economics.
There's lots of mysteries left to be unsolved,
but left to be solved.
But we are slightly wiser,
I presume then we were at one point.
And so you can forgive the authors to some degree for what they didn't know,
but that doesn't matter.
Given that the essence of this doctrine is still held as sacrosanct by a large
proportion of academics probably are among the most,
what would you call guilty of that particular sin?
So here's proposition number one.
History is to be viewed primarily as an economic class struggle.
All right,
so,
so let's think about that for a minute.
Um,
first of all,
is there,
the proposition there is that history is primarily to be viewed through an
economic lens.
And I think that's a debatable proposition because there are many other
motivations that drive human beings than economics.
And those have to be taken into account,
especially the drove people other than economic competition,
like economic cooperation for example.
And so that's a problem.
The other problem is that it's actually not nearly a pessimistic enough,
um,
description of the actual problem because history,
history,
this is to give the devil his due.
The idea that one of the driving forces between history is hierarchical struggle
is absolutely true.
But the idea that that's actually history is not true because it's deeper than
history.
It's biology itself because organisms have all sorts organized themselves into
hierarchies.
And one of the problems with hierarchies is that they tend to arrange themselves
into a winner,
take all situation.
And so,
and that that is implicit in some sense in Marx,
Marx is thinking because of course,
Marx believed that in a capitalist society,
capital would accumulate in the hands of fewer and fewer people.
And that actually is in keeping with the nature of hierarchical organizations.
Now the problem with that is it so much the fact of the,
so there's the,
there's accuracy in the accusation that that is a eternal form of motivation for
struggle.
But it's an underestimation of the seriousness of the problem because it
attributed to this structure of human societies rather than the deeper reality
of the existence of hierarchical structures per se,
which as they also characterize the animal kingdom to a large degree are clearly
not only human constructions and the idea that there's hierarchical competition
among human beings.
There's evidence for that.
That goes back at least to the Paleo Olympic Times.
And so that's the next problem.
It's that,
well,
the,
this ancient problem of hierarchical structure is clearly not attributable to
capitalism because it existed long in human history before capitalism existed
and then it predated human history itself.
So the question then arises,
why would you necessarily at least implicitly link the class struggle with
capitalism given that it's a far deeper problem.
And now it's also,
you got to understand that this is a deeper problem for people on the left,
not just for people on the right.
It is the case that hierarchical structures dispossess those people who are at
the bottom,
those creatures who are at the bottom speaking say of animals,
but those people who are at the bottom.
And that that is a fundamental existential problem.
I'll let,
the other thing that marks didn't seem to take into account is that there,
there,
there are far more reasons that human beings struggle then their economic class
struggle.
Even if you build the hierarchical idea into that,
which is a more comprehensive way of thinking about human beings,
struggle with themselves,
with the malevolence that's inside themselves with the evil that they're capable
of doing with the spiritual and psychological warfare that goes on within them.
And we're also actually always at odds with nature and this never seems to show
up in marks and it doesn't show up in Marxist Marxism in general,
it's as if nature doesn't exist.
The primary conflict as far as I'm concerned,
or a primary conflict that human beings engage engaging is the struggle for life
in a cruel and harsh natural world.
And it says,
if I just have,
that doesn't exist in the Marxists domain.
If human beings have a problem,
it's because there's a class struggle.
Let's essentially economic.
It's like,
no,
human beings have problems because we come into the life starving and lonesome
and we have to solve that problem continually.
And we make our social arrangements at least in part to ameliorate that as well
as to as to well upon occasion exacerbated.
And so there's also very little understanding in the communist manifesto that
any of the like say hierarchical organizations that human beings have put
together might have a positive element.
And that's an absolute catastrophe because hierarchical structures are actually
necessary to solve complicated social problems.
We have to organize ourselves in some manner and you have to give the devil his
due.
And so it is the case that hierarchies dispossessed people and that's a big
problem.
That's the fundamental problem of inequality.
But it's also the case that hierarchies happened to be a very efficient way of
distributing resources.
And it's finally the case that human hierarchies are not fundamentally
predicated on power.
And I would say that biological anthropological data on that are crystal clear.
You don't rise to a position of authority that's reliable in human society,
primarily by exploiting other people.
It's a very unstable means of obtaining power.
So,
so that's a problem.
Well,
the people that laugh might do it that way.
[inaudible]
okay.
Now the other,
another problem that comes up right away is that Mark's also assumes that you
can think about history as a binary class struggle with clear divisions between
say the proletariat,
proletariat and the bourgeoisie.
And that's actually a problem because it's not so easy to make a from division
between who's exploiter and who's exploiting,
let's say.
Um,
because it's not obvious,
like in the case of small shareholders,
let's say,
whether or not they happen to be part of the oppressed or part of the oppressor,
this actually turned out to be a big problem in the Russian revolution and buy
big problem.
I mean,
tremendously big problem because it turned out that you could fragment people
into multiple identities and that that's a fairly easy thing to do.
And you can usually find some access along which they were part of the oppressor
class.
It might have been a consequence of their education or it might be a consequence
of their,
of the wealth that they strived to accumulate during their life.
Or it might've been a consequence of the fact that they had parents or
grandparents who are educated to rich or that they're a member of the priesthood
or that they were socialists or any ways that the listing of how it was possible
for you to be bourgeois instead of proletariat grew immensely.
And that was one of the reasons that the red terror claimed all the victims that
it claimed.
And so that was a huge problem.
It was probably most exemplified by the demolition of the Kulaks who were
basically peasants,
peasant farmers,
although effective ones in the Soviet Union who had managed to raise themselves
out of serfdom over a period of about 40 years.
And together some,
some degree of material security about them.
And about 1.8 million of them were exiled,
uh,
about 400,000 were killed.
And the net consequence of that,
um,
removal of their private property because of their bourgeois status was arguably
the death of 6 million Ukrainians in the famines of the 1930s.
And so the binary class struggle idea that was a bad idea.
That was a very,
very bad idea.
It's also bad in this way.
And that,
and this is a real slight of hand that Mark's pulls off,
is you have a binary class division proletarian bourgeoisie,
and you have an implicit idea that all of the good is on the side of the
proletariat.
And all of the evil is on this side of the bourgeoisie.
And that's classic group identity thinking.
You know,
it was just one of the reasons I don't like identity politics is because once
you divide people into groups and pit them against one another,
it's very easy to assume that all the evil in the world can be attributed to one
group,
the hypothetical oppressors and all the good to the other and that.
Well,
and that's,
that's,
that's naive.
That's naive beyond comprehension because,
um,
it's absolutely foolish to make the presumption that you can identify someone's
moral worth with their economic standing.
So,
and that actually turned out to be a real problem as well because,
um,
Mark's also came up with his idea,
which is a crazy idea as far as I can tell of the,
that's a technical term,
crazy idea of the dictatorship of the proletariat.
And that's the next idea that I really stumbled across.
It was like,
okay,
so what's the problem?
Well,
the problem is the capitalists own everything.
They own all the means of production and they're oppressing everyone.
That would be all the workers.
And there's going to be a race to the bottom of wages for the workers as the
capitalist strive to extract more and more value from the Labor of the
proletariat by with other capitalists should drive wages downward,
which by the way,
didn't happen partly because wages,
wage earners can become scarce,
and that actually drives the market value upward.
But the fact that you assume a priori,
that all the evil can be attributed to the capitalists and all the good that the
bourgeoisie and all the good could be attributed to the proletariat meant that
you could hypothesize that a dictatorship of the proletariat could come about.
And that was the,
the first stage in the communist revolution.
And remember this is a call for revolution,
not just revolution,
but bloody violent revolution and the overthrow of all the overthrowing of all
existence,
social structures.
MMM.
Anyways,
the,
the problem with that you see is that because all the evil isn't divided so
easily up into oppressor and oppressed,
that when you do establish a dictator of the proletariat to the degree that you
can do that,
which you actually can't because it's technically impossible and an absurd thing
to consider to begin with not least because of the problem of centralization,
and you have to hypothesize that you can take away all the property of the
capitalists.
You can replace the capitalist class with a minority of pro proletariats.
How they're going to be chosen isn't exactly clear in the communist manifesto
that none of the people who are from the proletarian class are going to be
corrupted by that sudden access to power because they're well by definition.
Good.
So,
so then you have the good people who are running the world and you also have
them centralized so that they can make decision decisions that are insanely
complicated to make in fact impossibly complicated to make.
And so that's a failure conceptually on both dimensions because first of all,
all the proletariat aren't going to be good.
And when you give put people in the same position as the evil capitalists,
especially if you believe that social pressure is one of the determining factors
of human character,
which the Marxists certainly believed,
then why wouldn't you assume that the proletariat would immediately become as or
more corrupt than the capitalists,
which is of course,
I would say exactly what happened every time this experiment was run and then
[inaudible].
The next problem is,
well,
what makes you think that you can take some system as complicated as like
capitalist free market society and centralize that and put decision making power
in the hands of a few people.
The mechanisms by
without specifying the mechanisms by which you're going to choose them,
like what makes you think they're going to have the wisdom or the ability to do
what the capitalists were.
Unless you assume,
as Marx did that all of the evil ones with the capitalists and all the good was
with the proletariats and that nothing that capitalists did constituted valid
labor,
which is another thing that Marx assumed,
which is palpably absurd because people who are like maybe if you're a dissolute
aristocrat from 1830 and or earlier and you run a feudal estate and all you do
is spend your time gambling and,
and,
and chasing prostitutes,
well then your labor value is zero.
But if you're,
if you're running a business and,
and it's a successful business,
first of all,
you're a bloody fool to explore exploit your workers because even if you're
greedy as sin because you're not going to extract the maximum amount of labor
out of them by doing that and the notion that you're adding no productive value
as a manager rather than a capitalist is it's absolutely absurd.
All it does is indicate that you either know nothing whatsoever about how an
actual business works or you refuse to know anything about how an actual
business works.
So that's
[inaudible].
That's also,
that's also a big problem.
So then the next problem is the criticism of profit.
It's like,
well what's wrong with profit?
Exactly what,
what's the problem with profit?
Well,
the idea from the Marxist perspective was that profit was theft.
No one but profit well can be theft because crooked people can run companies and
so sometimes profit is theft,
but that certainly doesn't mean that it's always three theft.
What it means in part at least if the capitalist is adding value to the
corporation,
then there's some utility and some fairness in him or her extracting the value
of their abstract labor,
their thought,
their abstract abilities,
their ability to manage the company and to engage in proper competition in
product development and efficiency and the proper treatment of the workers and
all of that.
And then if they can create a profit,
well then they have a little bit of security for times that aren't so good.
And that seems absolutely bloody necessary as far as I'm concerned.
And then the next thing is,
well how can you grow if you don't have a profit?
And if you have an enterprise that's valuable and worthwhile and some
enterprises are valuable and worthwhile,
then it seems to me that a little bit of profit to help you grow seems to be the
right approach.
And so,
and then the other issue with profit,
and you know this,
if you've ever run a business is it,
it's really useful constraint.
You know,
like it's not enough to have a good idea.
It's not a good enough to have a good idea and a sales and marketing plan.
And then to implement that in all of that,
that's bloody difficult.
Like it's not easy to have a good idea.
And it's not easy to come up with a good sales and marketing plan.
And it's not easy to find customers and satisfy them.
And so if you allow profit to,
to a limitation on what it is that you might reasonably attempt,
it provides a good constraint on,
on wasted labor.
And so most of the things that I've done in my life,
even psychologically,
that were designed to help people,
psychological health,
I tried to run on a for profit basis.
And the reason for what that was,
apart from the fact that I'm not averse to making a profit,
partly so my enterprises can grow,
but it was also so that there were forms of stupidity that I couldn't engage in
because I would be punished by the market enough to eradicate the enterprise.
And so
[inaudible].
Okay.
And then,
so the next,
the next issue,
this is a weird one.
So Marx and Engels also assume that this dictatorship of the proletariat,
which involves observed centralization,
the overwhelming probability of corruption and impossible computation as the
proletariat now try to rationally compute the manner in which an entire market
economy could run,
which cannot be done because it's far too complicated for anybody to think
through.
Um,
the next theory is that somehow the proletariat dictatorship would become
magically hyper productive.
And there's actually no theory at all about how that's going to happen.
And so I had to infer the theory and the theory seems to be that once you
eradicate the bourgeoisie,
because they're evil and you get rid of their private property and Ew,
ew,
eradicate the profit motive,
then all of a sudden magically the small percentage of the proletariat who now
run the society determine how they can make their
productive enterprises productive enough.
So they become hyper productive now and they need to become hyper productive for
the last error to be logically coherent in relationship to the Marxist theory,
which is that at some point the proletariat,
the dictatorship of the proletariat will become so hyper productive that
there'll be enough material goods for everyone across all dimensions.
And when that happens,
then what people will do is spontaneously engage in meaningful creative labor,
which is what they had been alienated from in the capitalist horror show.
And the utopia will be magically ushered in,
but there's no indication about how that hyper productivity is going to come
about.
And there's no walls.
There's also no understanding that well that isn't the utopia that is going to
suit everyone because there are great differences between people when some
people are going to find what they want in love and some are going to find it in
social being in,
some are going to find it in conflict and competition and some are going to it
in creativity as mark pointed out.
But the notion that that that will necessarily be the end goal for the Utopian
state is preposterous.
And then there's the dusty in observation too,
which is one not to be taken lightly,
which is well,
what sort of shallow conception of people do you have that makes you think that
if you gave people enough bread and cake and the Dostoyevsky in terms and
nothing to do with busy them except the busy themselves with the continued to
continuity of the species,
that they would also all of a sudden become peaceful in heavenly Dostoyevsky's
idea was that,
you know,
we were built for trouble and if we were ever handed everything we were,
we needed on a silver platter,
the first thing we would do is engage in some form of creative destruction.
Just so something unexpected could happen just so we could have the adventure of
our lives.
And I think there's something,
there's something to be said for that.
[inaudible].
So and then the last error let's say,
although by no means the last was this,
and this is one of the strangest parts of the communist manifesto was Mark's it
agree,
admits and angels admit repeatedly in the Communist manifesto that there has
never been a system of production in the history of the world that was as
effective at producing material commodities in excess than capitalism.
Like that's,
that's extensively documented in the communist manifesto.
And so if your proposition is,
look,
we got to get as much material security for everyone as we as,
as possible,
as fast as we can.
And capitalism already seems to be doing that at a rate that's unparalleled in
human history within the logical thing be just to let the damn system play
itself out.
I mean,
unless you're assuming that the evil capitalists are just going to take all of
the flat screen televisions and put them in one big room and not let anyone else
have one,
the logical assumption is that while you're already on a road that's supposed to
produce the proper material productivity,
and so,
well that's 10 reasons as far as I can tell that.
And so what I saw in that did that that the communist manifesto is,
is like seriously flawed in,
in virtually every way it could possibly be flawed.
And also all in an in an um,
uh,
evidence that Marx was the kind of narcissistic thinker who could think he was,
he was very intelligent person.
And so it was angles,
but what he thought,
what he thought when he thought was that what he thought was correct and he
never went the second stage,
which is,
wait a second,
how could all of this go terribly wrong?
And if you're a thinker,
especially a sociological thinker especially I think are on the broad scale as a
social scientist,
for example,
one of your moral obligations is to think,
you know,
you might be wrong about one of your fundamental axioms or two or three 10 and
as a consequence you have the moral obligation to walk through the dam system
and think,
well what if I'm completely wrong here?
And things in divert and go exactly the wrong way.
Like I can't,
I just can't understand how anybody could come up with an idea like the
dictatorship of the proletariat,
especially after advocating it's implementation for with violent means,
which is a direct part of the communist manifesto.
And actually think if they were thinking,
if they knew anything about human beings and the proclivity for malevolence,
that's part and parcel of the individual human being that that could do anything
but lead to a special form of hell,
which is precisely what did happen.
And so I'm going to close because I have three minutes with,
with a bit of evidence as well,
that
Mark's also thought that what would happen inevitably as a consequence of
capitalism is that rich would get richer and the poor would get poorer.
So there would be inequality.
The first thing I'd like to say is we do not know how to set up a human system
of economics without inequality.
No one has ever managed it,
including the communists.
And the form of inequality changed.
And it's not obvious by any stretch of imagination that the free market
economies of the West have more inequality than the less free economy is in the
rest of the world.
And the one thing you can say about capitalism is that although it produces
inequality,
which it absolutely does,
it also produces wealth.
And all the other systems don't.
They just produce inequality.
[inaudible] so
here's,
here's a few stats.
Here's a few free market stats.
Okay.
Um,
from 1800 to 2017,
income growth adjusted for inflation grew by 40 times for production workers in
16 times for unskilled labor.
Um,
well,
GDP fact GDP rose by a factor of about 0.5 from one 80 to 1800.
So from 180880980,
it was like nothing flat.
And then all of a sudden in the last 217 years,
there's been this unbelievably upward movement of wealth.
And it doesn't only characterize the tiny percentage of people at the top who
admittedly do have most of the wealth.
The question is not only though what's the inequality,
the question is,
well,
what's happening to the absolutely poor at the bottom?
And answer to that is they are getting richer faster now than they ever have in
the history of the world.
And we're eradicating poverty
in countries that have adopted moderate free market policies at a rate that's
unparalleled.
So here's an example.
The UN millennial,
what are the UN millennial goals too,
was to reduce the,
the rate of absolute poverty in the world by 50% between 2000 and 2015 and they
define as a dollar 90 a day,
pretty low,
you know,
uh,
but you have to start somewhere.
Um,
we beat,
we hit that at 2012,
three years ahead of schedule.
And you might be cynical about that and say,
well,
it's kind of an arbitrary number,
but the curves are exactly the same at $3 and $83 and 80 cents a day at $7 and
60 cents a day.
Not as many people have hit that,
but the rate of increase towards that as the same,
the bloody u n thanks that will be out of poverty defined by a dollar 90 a day
by the year 2030.
It's unparalleled.
And so,
so the,
so the rich may be getting Richard,
but the poor are getting rich or too,
that's,
that's not the look,
I'll leave it at that.
Um,
because I'm out of time.
But one of the,
I'll leave it with this,
um,
the poor are not getting poor under capitalism.
The poor are getting richer under capitalism by a large margin.
And I'll leave you with one statistic,
which is that now,
um,
in in Africa,
the child mortality rate in Africa now is the same as the child mortality rate
was in Europe in 1952.
And so that's happened within the span of one lifetime.
And so if you're for the poor,
if you're for the poor,
if you're actually concerned that the poorest people in the world rise above
their starvation levels,
then the,
all the evidence suggests that the best way to do that is to implement something
approximating a free market economy.
And so
thank you very much.
[inaudible]
thank you,
Dr. Peterson.
Dr G,
Jake.
Thank you.
[inaudible] okay.
First,
a brief introductory remark.
I cannot,
but notice the irony of how Peter [inaudible] the participants in this UL of the
century are both marginalized by the official academic community.
I'm supposed to defend here the left liberal line against neoconservative.
Really,
most of the attacks on me,
I don't know precisely from left liberals.
Just remember the outcry against my critique of LGBT plus ideology and time.
Sure.
That if the leading figures in the field ready to be asked,
if I even feet to stand for them,
they will turn in their grave even if they're still alive.
So let me begin by bringing together the three notions from the title happiness,
communism,
capitalism in one exemplary case,
China today,
China in the last decades is arguably the greatest economic success story in
human history.
Can't reach of millions raised from poverty into middle class existence.
How did trying to achieve it?
The 20th century left was defined by its opposition to the two fundamental
tendencies of modernity,
the reign of capital we teach aggressive market competition,
the authoritarian bureaucratic state power.
Today's China combines these two features in each extreme forum,
strong,
authoritarian state,
state,
wild capitalists dynamics,
and it's important to note they do it on behalf of cattiness.
Of the majority of people,
they don't mention communism to legitimize their rule.
They prefer the old [inaudible] notion of a harmonious society.
But are the Chinese any happier for all that?
Although even the Dalai Lama justifies Tibetan Buddhism in Western terms of the
pursuit of happiness and the avoidance of pain.
Happiness as a goal of our life is very problematic notion.
If we learned anything from psycho analysis,
it is that we humans are very creative in sabotaging our pursuit of happiness.
Happiness is a confused notion.
Basically,
it relies on the subject in ability or unreadiness to fully confront the
consequences of his shirt,
their desire in our daily lives.
We pretend to desire things which we don't not really desire,
so that ultimately the worst thing that can happen is for us to get what we
officially desire.
So I agreed that human life of freedom and dignity does not consist Justin
searching for happiness.
No matter how much we spiritualize it or in the effort to actualize our inner
potentials,
we have to find some meaningful cause beyond the mural struggle for pleasurable
survival.
However,
I would like to add here a couple of
qualifications.
First,
since we live in a modern era,
we cannot simply refer to an unquestionable authority to confer emission or
tasks on us.
Modernity means that yes,
we should carry the burden,
but the main burden is freedom itself.
We are responsible for our burdens.
Not only are we not allowed trip excuses for not doing our duty.
Duty itself should not serve as an excuse.
We are never blessed instrument of some higher cause.
Once traditional authority loses its substantial power,
it is not possible to return to eat.
All such returns are today a postmodern fake.
Does Donald Trump stand for traditional values?
No,
he's conservativism is the postmodern performance.
I began tick ego trip in this sense of playing with traditional values of mixing
references to them with open obscenities.
Trump is the ultimate postmodern president.
If we compare Trump with Bernie Sanders,
Trump is the postmodern politician at its purest.
While senders is rather an old fashioned moralist,
conservative thinkers claim that the origin of our crisis is the loss of our
reliance on some transcendent divinity or higher value if we are left to
ourselves.
If everything is historically conditioned and relative,
then there is nothing preventing us to indulge in our lowest tendencies.
But is this really the lesson to be learned from mob killing,
looting,
and burning on behalf of religion?
It is often claimed that true or not religion make some otherwise bad people do
good things from today's experience.
I think we should rather stick to Steve Weinberg claim that while without
religion,
good people would have been doing good things and the bad people,
bad things.
Only something like religion can make good people do bad things.
More than a century ago in his brothers Karamazov Dostoyevsky warned against the
dangers of godless,
godless moral mutualism.
If God doesn't exist,
then everything is permitted.
The French philosopher and Glucksman applied the stair skis critique of a
godless myths Elysium to September 11th and the title of his Book Dostoyevsky in
Manhattan suggest that as the title suggests,
he couldn't have been more wrong.
The lesson of today's terrorism is that if there is a god,
then everything even blowing up hundreds of innocent bystanders is permitted to
those who claim to act directly on behalf of God.
The same ghosts also for Godless,
Stalinists Communist.
They are the ultimate proof of it.
Everything was permitted to them since they perceived themselves as direct
instrument of their divinity,
of the historical necessity of progress towards communism.
That's the big problem of radiologists.
How to make good,
decent people do horrible things.
Second,
yes,
we should carry our burden.
Accept the suffering that goes with it,
but a danger lurks here that have a subtle reversal.
Don't fall in love,
that might position with your suffering.
Never presumed that your suffering is in itself.
A proof of your authenticity and Annunciation of pleasure can easily turn into
pleasure of renunciation itself.
For example,
an example not from New York,
conservative white left liberals love to denigrate their own culture and blame
Eurocentrism for our evils,
but it is instantly clear how this self denigration brings a profit of its own
through this renouncing
of their particular routes.
Multicultural liberals reserved for themselves,
the universal position graciously soliciting other's to assert their particular
identity.
White multiculturalists liberals embodied the lie of identity politics.
Next point.
Zach LACOE wrote something paradoxical but deeply true that even if what,
uh,
a jealous husband claims about his,
about his wife,
that she sleeps with other men is all true.
His jealousy is nonetheless pathological.
The Palette pathological element is the husband's neat for glog is the only way
for him to sustain his identity.
Along the same lines,
one could say that even if most of the Nazi claims about goose,
they exploited gentleman's,
they should use German girls and so on where through which they were not of
course that antisemitism would still be pathological phenomenon because it
ignored the true reason why the Nazis need that antisemitism in the Nazi vision.
Their society is an organic whole of harmonious collaboration,
so an external intruder is needed to account for divisions and antagonisms.
The same holds for how today in Europe at least the anti-immigrant populists
deal with the refugees.
The cost of problems we clarify,
I claim imminent to today's global capitalism is projected onto an external
intruder.
Again,
even if the reported incident with the refugees that are great problems.
I admitted even all these reports are true.
The published story about them is alive with antisemitism.
We are the topic of telling stories.
Hit Hitler was one of the greatest storytellers of the 20th century.
In the 1920s
many Germans experienced their situation as a confused mess.
They didn't understand what is happening to them with military defeat,
economic crisis,
what they perceived as moral decay and so on.
She provided a story,
a plot,
which was precisely that of a Jewish plot.
We are in this mess because of the juice.
That's what I would like to insist on.
We are telling ourselves stories about ourselves in order to acquire a
meaningful experience of our lives.
However,
this is not enough.
One of the most stupid wisdoms and they are mostly stupid,
is an enemy is someone who's story you have not hurt.
Really they is is are you also ready to affirm that Hitler was our enemy because
he story was not hurt.
The experience that we have of our lives from within the story we tell ourselves
about ourselves in order to account for what we are doing is,
and this is what I call it,
theology,
fundamentally a lie.
The truth lies outside in what we do.
In a similar way,
the old trite obsession with cultural Marxism expresses the rejection to
confront the fact that the phenomena they criticize as the effect of the
cultural Marxist plot,
moral degradation,
sexual promiscuity,
consumers had an aneurysm and so on are the outcome of the imminent dynamic of
capitalist societies.
I would like to refer to a classic Danielle Bell cultural contradictions of
capitalism written back in 1976 where the author argues that the unbounded,
the drive of modern capitalism undermines the moral foundations of the original
Protestant ethics and in the new afterwards they'll offers embracing perspective
on contemporary Western societies.
Revealing the crucial cultural fault lines we face as the 21st century is here.
The turn toward sculpture is a key component of capitalist reproduction and
concomitant to eat.
The commodification of cultural life itself are I think crucial moments of
capitalists,
expanded reproduction.
So the term cultural Marxism,
I think plays the same role as that of the Jewish plot in antisemitism it
projects or can supposedly some [inaudible].
I'm Taco Neesan,
however you call it,
ambiguity,
tension of our social economic life on an external costs in exactly the same
way.
Now let me tell you a different,
give you a different model.
Problematic example in exactly the same way liberal critics of Trump and
outright never seriously asked how our liberal society could give birth to
Trump.
In this sense,
the image of Donald Trump is also a fetish.
The last think illiberal sees before confronting actual social tangents.
Hegel's motto,
evil resides in the gaze,
which is evil.
Everywhere fully applies here.
The very liberal gaze with demonizes Trump is also evil because it ignores how
its own failures opened up the space for Trump stype of patriotic populism.
Next point,
one,
stop blaming head on East EquityZen for our worlds,
the true opposite of equities.
Shelflife is not altruism,
a concern for the common good,
but envy,
resentment,
which makes me act against my own interest.
This is why as many perspicuous to philosophers clearly saw evil is profoundly
spiritual in some sense,
more spiritual than goodness.
This is why egalitarianisms itself should never be accepted at its face value.
It can well secretly envelop the standard renunciation accomplished to benefit
others.
Egalitarianism often facto means I am ready to renounce something so that others
will also not habit.
This is,
I think now comes the problematic part for some of you may be the problem with
political correctness.
What appears as it's excesses,
it's regulatory zeal is I think an impotent reaction to that masks the reality
of a defeat.
My hero is here,
a black lady,
Tirana Burke,
who created the me too campaign more than a decade ago.
She observed in a recent critical note debt in the years since the movement
began.
It deployed.
An unwavering obsession with the perpetrators meet too is all too often
adrenaline protests filtered through resentment.
Should we then drop egalitarianism?
No.
Equality can also mean and that's the quality.
I advocate creating the space for as many as possible individuals to develop
their different potentials.
It is that my paradoxical claim,
if this today's capitalism that equalizes us to mark and causes the loss of many
talents,
so what about the balance between equality and he did we really move too much in
the direction of equality?
Is there in today's United States really too much equality?
I think a simple overview of the situation points in the opposite direction far
from pushing us too far.
The left is gradually losing its ground already for decades.
It's trademarks,
universal healthcare,
free education and so on are continuously diminished.
Look at Bernie Sanders in that don't idealize him program.
It is just
a version of what half a century ago in Europe was simply the predominant social
democracy and it's today decried as a threat to our freedoms to the American way
of life and shown and so on.
I see no threat in two free creativity in this program.
On the contrary,
I see healthcare and education and so on as enabling me to focus my life on more
important creative issues.
I see equality,
this basic equality of transition as a space for creating differentiation and
yes,
why not even different,
more appropriate here,
Cheryl,
he's furthermore,
I find it very hard to ground today's inequalities as they are documented.
For example,
by Piketty in his book on
to ground today's inequalities in different competencies.
Competencies for what in totalitarian states competencies are determined
politically,
but market success is also not innocent and neutral.
As a regulator of the social recognition of competencies,
let me know briefly deal
with uh,
in a friendly way.
I claim with what became known story for the irony is the lobster topic.
I'm far from a simple social construction is in here.
I deeply appreciate evolutionary thought.
Of course,
we are also natural beings and our DNA,
as we all know,
overlaps.
I may be wrong around 98% with debt of some monkeys.
This means something,
but nature,
I think we should never forget,
this is not a stable hierarchical system,
but full of improvisations.
It develops like French cuisine.
A French guy gave me this idea that French,
the origin of many famous French deeply or drinks is that when they wanted to
produce a standard piece of food or drink,
something went wrong,
but then they realize that this trailer can be resold as success.
They were making cheese in the usual way,
but the trees got rotten and infect that smelling bad and they said,
oh my God,
look,
we have our own original French trees or they were making wine in the usual way.
Then something went wrong with fermentations and so they began to produce some
pain and so on and so on.
I am not making just a joke here because I think that it is exactly like this,
that and that's the lessons of psycho analysis that our sexuality works.
Sexual instincts are of course biologically determined,
but look what we humans made out of them.
They are not limited to the mating season.
They can develop in a permanent up into a permanent obsession,
sustained by obstacles that demand to be overcome in short into appropriately
metaphysical passion that perturbs the biological rhythm with twitch,
like endlessly prolonged in satisfaction in courtly love,
engaging in different perversions and so on and so on.
So it still,
yes,
biologically conditioned sexuality,
but it is,
if I may use this term trans functionalized,
it becomes a moment of a different cultural,
however you call it,
logic and I claim the same goes for tradition.
DSL,
yet the great conservative route pope.
What happens when a new work of art is created is something that happens
simultaneously to all the work of art which preceded it.
The past should be altered by the present as much as the present is directed by
the past and have quote,
what does this mean?
Let me mention the change enacted by Christianity.
It's not just that in spite of all our natural and cultural differences,
the same divine spark dwells in everyone,
but this divine spark enables us to create what Christians Call Holy Ghost or
Holy Spirit.
A community in which he had our family values are at some level at least
abolished.
Remember Paul's words from Galatians.
There is no longer Jew or Greek.
There is no longer male and female in Christ.
A democracy extends this logic to the political space.
In spite of all differentiation in competence,
the ultimate decision should stay with all of us.
The wager of democracy is that we should not give all power to competent
experts.
It was precisely communist in power who legitimize that rule by posing fake
And incidentally,
I'm far from believing in ordinary people's wisdom.
We often need a master figure to push us out of an inertia,
and I am not afraid to say that forces us to be free.
Freedom and responsibility hurt that required an effort and the highest function
of an authentic master is to literally to awaken us to our freedom.
We are not spontaneously really three.
Furthermore think,
I think that social power and authority cannot be directly grounded in
competence in our human universe.
Power in the sense of exerting authority is something much more mysterious.
Even irrational Kierkegaard,
my and everybody's favorite theologist wrote,
if a child says he [inaudible] his father because his father is a con competent
and good guy.
This is an affront to father's authority and he applied the same logic to Christ
himself.
Christ was justified by the fact of being got son,
not by his competencies or capacities as Kierkegaard put it.
Every good student of theology can put things better than Christ.
This there is no such authority in nature.
Lobsters may have Cheryl,
he undoubtedly,
but the main guy among them,
I don't think he has authority in the sense,
again,
the wager of democracy is that and that's the subtle thing,
not against competence and so on,
but that political power and competence or expertise should be kept apart in
Stalinism.
Precisely.
They were not kept apart while already in ancient Greece.
They knew that they have to be kept apart,
which is why they're popular.
Weight was even combined with Lateri often,
so where does communism,
just to conclude,
where does communism enter here?
Why do I still cling to this first name?
When I know in fully admit the 20th century Communist project in all its
failure,
how it failed giving birth to new forms of murderous terror capitalism one but
today and that's my claim,
we can debate about it.
The question is that's today's global capitalism contained strong enough
antagonisms which prevent it's indefinite reproduction.
I think there are such antagonisms the threat of ecological catastrophe,
the consequence of new techno scientific developments,
especially in viral genetics and new forms of apart,
apart,
right?
All this antagonism is concerned what Marx called Commons,
the sheriff substance of our social big first of course the common of external
nature,
threatened by pollution,
global warming and so on.
Now let me be precise here.
I am well aware of how uncertain analysis and projections are in this domain.
It will be certain only when it will be too late and I am well aware of the
temptation to engage in precipitous extrapolations.
When I was younger.
To give you a critical example,
there was in Germany and obsession with Val Starobin,
the dying of forest with predictions debt in a couple of decades.
Europe will be without forests,
but according to recent estimates,
there are now more forest areas in Europe then 100 years or 50 years ago.
But there is nonetheless,
I claim the prospect of a catastrophe here.
Scientific data seemed to me at least abandoned enough and we should act in a
large scale collective way.
And I also think this may be critical to some of you.
There is a problem with capitalism,
care for the simple reason that it's managers not because of data evil nature,
but that's the logic of capitalism.
Care to expand self reproduction and environmental consequences are simply not
part of the game.
This is again not a moral reproach in incidentally so that you will not think
that I don't know what I'm talking about.
In Communist countries,
those empower were obsessed with expanded pre production and we're not under
public control.
So the situation was even worse.
So how to act first by admitting we are in a deep mass.
There is no simple democratic solution here.
The idea that people themselves should decide what to do about ecology sounds
deep,
but it backs an important question even with their comprehension is not
distorted by corporate interests.
What qualifies them to pass a judgment in such a delicate matter?
Plus the radical measures advocated by some ecologists can themselves trigger
new catastrophes.
Let me mention just the idea which is floating around of solar radiation
management.
The continuous massive dispersal of Iris falls into our atmosphere to reflect
and absorb sunlight and that's cool.
The planet.
Can we even imagine how the fragile balance of our earth function and in what
unpredictable ways geo engineering can disturb eat in such times of urgently
when we know we have to act but don't know how to act.
Thinking is needed.
Maybe we should turn around a little bit.
Mark famous physics 11 in that in our new century we should say that maybe in
the last century we tried all too fast to change the world.
The time has come to step back and interpreted.
The second threat,
the Commons of internal nature with new biogenetic technologist,
the creation of a new man in the literal sense of changing human nature becomes
a realistic prospect.
I mean primarily so-called popularly link the direct link between our brain and
digital machines and then brains among themselves.
This I think is the true game changer.
The digitalization of our brain opens up.
I'm hurt of new possibilities of control directly sharing your experience with
your beloved may appear attractive,
but what about chatting them with an agency without you even knowing it?
Finally,
the common space of humanity itself.
We live in one in the same world which is more and more interconnected but
nonetheless deeply divided so how to react to this.
The first and sadly predominant reaction is the one of protective self
enclosure.
The world out there is in a mess.
Let's protect ourselves by all kinds of walls.
It seems that our countries are around relatively well but is the mess.
The so called ropes countries find themselves in not connected to how we
interact with them.
Take what is perhaps the ultimate rogue state Kongo warlords who rule province
is there are always dealing with Western companies selling them minerals.
Where would our computers be without Colton from Congo and mark about foreign
intervention in Iraq and Syria or by our proxies like Saudi Arabia in Yemen.
Here refugees are created a new work order is emerging world of can I just
finish the page?
Two minutes.
Literally a world of peaceful coexistence of civilizations,
but in what way does he traction?
Forced marriages and homophobic homophobia are okay.
Just that they are really limited,
limited to another country which is otherwise fully included into the world
market.
This is how refugees again are created.
The secondary action is global capitalism with a human face.
Think about socially responsible corporate figures like Bill Gates or George
Sorrows.
They passionately support LGBT.
They advocate clarity and Chavon,
but even in the extreme forum,
opening up our borders to refugees,
treating them like one of us,
they only provide what is made between what in medicine is called a symptomatic
treatment.
This solution is not for [inaudible] Western countries to receive all
immigrants,
but somehow to try to change the situation which creates massive waves of
immigration and
we are completely in.
This
is such a change,
a utopia.
No,
that through your Tapia is that we can survive without subject change.
So here I think,
I know it's provocative to call this a bleed.
Bar Communism.
I do eat a little bit to provoke things,
but what is needed is nonetheless in all these fears,
I claim a call,
Oh gee,
did you tell control
you need to have a capitalist market,
which does great think I admitted have to be somehow limit that,
regulate that and so on.
Before you say it's a utopia,
I will tell you,
but let's think about in what way global market already fund clings to date.
I always thought that neoliberalism is a fake term.
If you look closely,
you will see that state place today more important role than ever precisely in
the capitalist economy.
So you know the market is already limited,
but not in the right way to put it nicely.
So especially means to conclusion what will happen in spite of protest here and
there.
We will probably continue to fly to or some kind of apocalypse awaiting large
catastrophes to awake enough.
So I don't accept any peep optimism when somebody tries to convince me that in
spite of all the problems that is a light at the end of the tunnel.
My instant reply.
Yes.
And it's probably another train coming to work,
sir.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
please don't do this because I really think that's my,
I,
I hope you [inaudible] bet why we are here.
Engage in this debate.
Don't take it as a keep competition.
It may be debt,
but we are,
as you said in your introduction,
desperately trying to confront curious problems.
I did.
What is junk food?
When I mentioned China,
China,
I didn't mean to celebrated.
That worries me terribly.
My goat.
Is this our future?
No,
no.
Sorry.
Sorry for the story.
Please discount.
Take away this from my 10 minutes.
No,
no problem.
No problem.
That'd Peterson.
10 minutes to you to reply.
So
I like to speak extemporaneously,
but doctors Egx,
um,
discussion was so complex that there's no way that I can juggle my responses
spontaneously,
so cheap.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
and,
and achievement managed,
I would say.
Um,
so,
so I heard much of,
I heard much of what I heard I agreed with.
Um,
but we can get to that.
I'm going to respond
well,
I lived the knife.
All right.
All right,
well,
hi.
I heard a criticism of capitalism,
but no real supportive Marxism and,
and that's an interesting thing because for me,
the,
the terms of the argument,
we're of other,
the three terms of the argument,
let's say there was capitalism,
there was Marxism and there was happiness and I would say dark DJ focus probably
more on the problems of capitalism and the problems of happiness then on the
utility of Marxism.
And that actually comes as a surprise to me because I presume that much of what
I would hear would be a support of something approximating traditional or even a
traditional Marxism,
which is why I organized the first part of my talk
as an attack against Marxism per se.
Okay.
So now she's here
points out that there are problems of capitalism.
And I would like to say that I'm perfectly aware that there are problems with
capitalism.
Um,
I wasn't defending capitalism actually.
In some sense I was defending it in comparison to communism,
which is not the same thing because as Winston Churchill said about democracy,
you know,
it's the worst form of government there is except for all the other forms.
And so you might say the same thing about capitalism is that it's the worst form
of economic arrangement you can possibly manage except for every other one that
we've ever tried.
And that,
and I'm dead serious about that.
I'm not trying to be flippant.
I mean that it isn't obvious to me.
And when doctors use jack is speaking in more apocalyptic terms,
it isn't obvious to me that we can solve the problems that confront us,
you know,
and it,
it's not also not a message that I have been purveying that unbridled capitalism
per se,
as an isolated,
what would you say social economic structure actually constitutes the proper
answer to the problems that confront us.
So I haven't made that case in any of the lectures that I've,
anything I've written or any of the lectures that I've done because I don't
believe it to be true.
He said,
well,
what's the problems with capitalism?
Well,
the commodification of cultural life,
all life,
fair enough.
Um,
there's something that isn't exactly right about reducing everything to economic
competition and capitalism certainly pushes in that direction.
Advertising culture pushes in that direction.
Sales and marketing culture pushes in that direction and there's reasons for
that.
And I have a certain amount of admiration for the necessity of advertisers and
salesmen and marketers,
but that doesn't mean that the transformation of all elements of life into
element,
into commodities in a capitalist sense is the best way forward.
I don't think it is the best way forward.
Um,
I think the evidence for that is actually quite clear.
There is,
by the way,
a relationship,
this is something I didn't point out before.
There is a relationship between wealth and happiness.
It's quite well defined in the psychological literature.
Now,
it's not exactly obvious whether the happiness measures are measures of
happiness or whether they're measures of the absence of misery.
And my sense is as a psychometrician who's looked at these scales that people
are more concerned with not being miserable than they are with being happy.
And those are all actually separate,
uh,
emotional states mediated by different psycho biological systems.
But it's a technical point but it's an important one.
The,
there is a relationship between absolute level of income and self reported,
lack of misery or happiness and it's pretty linear until you hit,
I would say something approximating decent working class income.
And so what seems to happen is that wealth makes you happy as long as it keeps
the bill collectors at bay.
Like once you've got to the point where the misery is staved off as much as it
can be by the fact that you're not absolutely in your not in absolutely
economically dire straights,
then adding more money to your life has no relationship whatsoever to your
wellbeing.
And so it's clear that past a certain minimal point,
additional material provision is not sufficient to let's say redeem us
individually or socially.
And it's certainly the case that the radical wealth production that
characterizes capitalism might produce a fatal threat to the structure of our
social systems and our broader ecosystems.
Who knows?
I'm not absolutely convinced of that for a variety of reasons.
I mean,
Jack pointed out,
for example,
that there are more forests in Europe now than there were a hundred years ago.
There's actually more forest in the entire northern hemisphere than there were a
hundred years ago.
And the news on the ecological
front is not as dismal as the people who put out the most dismal news would have
you think.
And there is some possibility.
That doesn't mean that there aren't elements of it that are dismal.
You know,
what we've done to the oceans is definitely something catastrophic and we,
we definitely have our problems,
but it is possible that human ingenuity might solve that.
Um,
what else?
There are inequalities generated by capitalism,
a proclivity towards a shallow materialism,
the probability of corruption.
Um,
the thing about that for me is those are catastrophes that are part of the
struggle for human existence itself and not something to be laid at the feet of
any given social political system,
especially one that seems to be producing a fair modicum of wealth for the
poorest section of the population.
And raising people up to the point where,
you know,
they,
their lives aren't unending an unending day to day struggle for mere survival.
And there's some evidence,
for example,
that if you can get GDP up to about $5,000 per person per year,
oh,
that's GDP,
um,
that people start to become concerned about environmental degradation and start
to take actions to prevent it.
And so there is some possibility that if we're lucky,
we can get the bottom billion or 2 billion people in the world,
or 3 billion as the population grows up to the point where they're wealthy
enough.
So they actually start to care enough about the environment so that we could act
collectively to solve environmental problems.
Now you might say,
well by that time we'll be out of earth.
You know,
we'll have,
we'll have exhausted the resources that are in front of us so desperately that
there's no hope of that.
But I would like to remind you of a famous bet between Julian Simon and um,
the biologist at at Stanford who wrote Paul Erlick who wrote the population
bomb.
They bet Eric who thought we were going to be overpopulated by the year 2000
bet,
Simon,
that by the year 2000 commodity prices would have increased dramatically as a
consequence of evidence that we were running out of material resources.
They made a famous bet over a 25 year period and Erlick paid off Simon in the
year 2000 because commodity prices went down and not up.
And so there is no solid evidence that the fact that our population is growing
and will peak out,
by the way,
at about 9 billion,
there's no solid indication that the consequence of that is that we are in fact
running out of necessary material resources.
And so it's a danger.
But if there's,
it's not a danger that's proven.
And there is some utility and considering that the addition of several billion
more brains to the planet,
especially if they were well nourished brains as they increasingly are,
might help us generate enough problem solvers so that we can stay ahead of the
looming ecological catastrophe has our population balloons outwards.
Now we're going to peak at 9 billion.
It's not much higher than we are now and it looks like we might be able to
manage it.
Um,
the,
uh,
the other thing is that I didn't hear an alternative really from doctor
[inaudible],
you know,
he,
he admitted the rise to success of the Chinese was in part a consequence of the,
of the allowance of market forces and decried the authoritarian tendencies.
And Fair enough,
that's exactly it.
It also seemed to me that the social justice group identity processes that
Doctor d did you use Yak was decrying art to me,
a logical derivation from the oppression narrative.
That's a fundamental presupposition of Marxism.
So there,
I'd never heard a defense of Marxism and that part of his argument as well.
And so for me,
again,
it's to ask what's the alternative?
Um,
I also heard an argument for egalitarianism and but how I heard it defined as
equality of opportunity,
not as equality of outcome,
which I see as a clearly defined Marxist aim.
I heard an argument for a modified social distribution of wealth,
but that's already part and parcel of most modern free market states with a wide
variation and inappropriate variation of government intervention,
all of which constitute their own experiment.
We don't know how much social intervention is necessary to flatten tendency of
hierarchies to become tilted so terribly that only the people at the top have
everything and all of the people at the bottom have nothing.
It's a very difficult battle to fight against that profound tendency,
much deeper than the tendency of capitalism itself.
And we don't exactly know what to do about it.
So we run experiments and that seems to be working perfectly reasonably as far
as I can tell.
Um,
let's see.
Well,
I'll,
I'll close with this.
Capitalism in the free market.
Well that's the worst form of social organization possible as I said,
except for all the others.
There is a positive relationship between economics measure by income and
happiness or psychological wellbeing,
which might be the absence of misery.
I certainly do not believe,
and the evidence does not suggest that material security is sufficient.
I do believe however,
that insofar as there is a relationship between happiness and materials
security,
that the free market system has demonstrated itself as the most efficient manner
to achieve that.
And that was actually the terms of the argument.
So thus,
if it's capitalism versus Marxism with regards to human happiness,
it's still the case that the free market constitutes the clear winner and maybe
capitalism will not solve our problems.
I actually don't believe that it will.
I in fact argued that the proper pathway forward is one of individual moral
responsibility aimed at the highest good.
And something for me that's rooted in our underlying Judeo Christian tradition
that insists that each person is uh,
uh,
what is his sovereign in their own right and a locus of,
of,
of ultimate value,
which is something that you can accept regardless of your religious
presuppositions and something that you do accept if you participate in a society
such as ours.
Even the fact that you vote that you're charged with that responsibility is an
indication that our society is structured such that we presume that each person
is a locus of responsibility and making of such import that the very stability
of the state depends upon the integrity of their,
um,
psych,
the integrity,
the integrity of their character.
And so what I've been suggesting to people is that they adopt as much
responsibility as they possibly can in keeping with that,
in keeping with their aim at the highest possible.
Good.
Which to me is something approximating a balance between what's good for you as
an individual and what's good for your family in keeping with what's good for
you as an individual.
And then what's good for society.
And the larger frame such that it's also good for you and your family.
And that's a form of an well an elaborated it rated game,
a form of elaborated cooperation.
It's a sophisticated way of looking at the ways society could possibly be
organized.
And I happen to believe that that has to happen at the individual level first
and that's the pathway forward that I see.
And so that's my tip.
[inaudible]
thank you Dr. Peterson.
Dr Jay.
Jay spent a little bit of my time.
I will try to be as short as possible.
So a couple of remarks and then my final point,
why I think the shelf limitation of capitalism isn't needed first about
happiness.
Just a couple of remarks.
Lauren,
I want to ask you but isn't it I am I dreaming?
I think I'm not.
I remember a couple of years ago it was your fault at all around the world.
Some kind of
investigation percentage of people interviewed in different countries.
Do they feel happy with their life?
And the shock was that some Scandinavian countries,
which we,
which we concede that social democratic paradise,
you got a very low while.
Bangladesh I think was close to the top.
Now I know this logic has a limit.
I don't buy the bullshit of pool.
People are happy in the world there and so on.
But you know,
my argument is not against you.
My argument here problematizing happiness even more.
Look,
Dick may interest you.
I was year ago in uh,
in I think Lithuania and we debated [inaudible] in one of my books.
When we're people in some pervert that change,
and this is the critique of the category of happiness for me,
Gabby and we came to the crazy result after the Soviet intervention,
Czechoslovakia in 1970s and eighties.
Why for happiness first you don't have,
you should not have too much democracy because this brings the burden of
responsibility.
Happiness means there is another guy out there.
You can put the blame on him and as the joke went in Czechoslovakia,
if there is bad weather,
a storm or this communist screwed it up again,
that's one condition of happiness.
The other condition,
much more subtle ones is,
and this was done in Czechoslovakia,
did those dark times after.
So the life was relatively moderately good but not perfect.
Like there was neat all the time.
Maybe once a month there was not meat in the stores.
It was very good to remind you how happy you are.
The other times and other thing they had a paradise which should be at the
appropriate distance.
West Germany affluence,
it was not too far but not directly accessible.
You know,
so I I it was so maybe in your critique of communist regimes,
I agree with you,
you should more focus on something that I experience of,
you know,
don't look only at the terror.
Ultimately totalitarian regime,
there was a kind of a silent perverted pact between,
at least in this late,
little bit more tolerant,
but they still publish them.
Communist regimes between power and population.
The message was leave us the power,
don't Mesh it with us and we guarantee you a relatively safe life.
Employment,
private players,
there's private niche and so on and so on.
So I am not sure priced,
but again,
this is not for me the argument for the communist but against happiness.
That's,
you know,
people said when,
uh,
when the wall fell down,
what the wonder in Poland,
my goat in,
in,
uh,
like solely Darnos which was prohibited a year ago now triumph at the elections.
Who could imagine these?
Yes,
but the true miracle in a bad sense for me was four years later,
democratically x communist came back to power.
So,
you know,
don't,
again,
this is for me,
not the argument for them,
but simply for the,
let's call it corruptive nature of happiness.
So my formula,
maybe you agree with it,
is my basic dogma is setting this should be treated as a necessary byproduct.
If you focus on it,
you are lost.
It comes as a byproduct of you working for a cause and so on.
That's the basic thing.
For second point,
maybe we disagree here.
China,
of course the miracle economic miracle was due to unleashing a market report and
so on.
But and here comes my passion museum.
Some of my liberal friends are telling me,
yes.
Imagine what would they have achieved with also political democratization.
I'm a passionist here.
No,
they found a perfect formula of how,
and that is the paradox of China today.
The Communist Party is the best men at [inaudible] of capitalism and protector
against workers.
The truly dangerous thing in China today is not to flirt with Western ideas,
is to organize trade unions too.
You know,
like this is what worries me,
this perfect combination between unleashing capitalism and still the
authoritarian rule or to put it in another way,
my worry is debt today,
all around the world,
this eternal marriage between capitalism and democracy is slowly disappearing
till now.
I admitted capitalism need that from time to time.
Some 10 20 years of dictatorship when things started to improve democracy,
return [inaudible],
South Korea and so on.
I wonder if we are still at that now at just very quickly,
your basic point in the introduction,
in your introduction,
you know,
I almost am tempted to say the way you presented communist manifesto,
the simplified image and Trayvon Trayvon.
It's crazy to say,
but on many points it,
I agree with you and it's a very complex argument.
Marx didn't have,
for example,
a good theory of how social power exists.
His idea was simply [inaudible] disappearance of class structure.
It secretly,
although he wouldn't have accepted it a technocratic dream,
like by experts social life will be around exert a perfect machine.
Although he was at least aware of the problem,
which is why he was so enthusiastic marks about Paris commune,
you know,
which was precisely not centralized power.
So I'm not just defending marks,
I'm saying it was not clear to him.
And uh,
uh,
so let's drop that.
Maybe I have more interesting things to say.
Ah,
another point.
Uh,
nonetheless,
uh,
where,
where at one point I'm ready to take.
Where did you find this discourse maybe for today's politically correct drugs
and so on that this,
uh,
egalitarianisms,
there is one passage in his late critique of gotta program where Mark's directly
addresses the problem of equality and he dismisses it as a strick bourgeois
category explicitly,
explicitly for him,
communism is not egalitarianism.
It's yes,
here are his but not based on capitalism.
Okay.
I am not totally defending earmarks.
I'm just saying don't republish the much.
Okay,
but to complete because yes,
I want to keep my promise to be a little bit shorter.
You know,
I agree with you on many points,
but you know what?
My problem with
my problem that I was aiming at with all of the openings,
I know we don't know really what is happening with ecology and Shavon who,
and this is an okay,
let's take oceans.
You mentioned them,
but isn't it for me?
Correct me if I'm wrong and I don't mean this rhetorically,
maybe I'm really wrong,
but the problem of oceans can,
the only way for me is some kind of cooperative international actions and Shawan
you cannot simply leave it to the market.
That's what I'm saying.
This is tasteful limit that I see about this diminishing poverty and so on.
I am aware of it.
I tend to agree with I also,
but I at the same time,
she show many explosive tensions.
For example,
do you know about South Africa?
It's a terrifying situation on the edge of the civil war to be very brutal.
The only thing that I can simplify it that really happened with end of apartheid
is that the old ruling class,
a simplified in grotesque mark,
Stan was joined by a new black ruling class,
which is not doing a good job so they are trying to play the race card.
It's still the consequence of white colonialism and so on and so on,
but the tangents are terrifying and here I was pleading for not abolishing
borders and so on,
but this type of,
I don't know how to put it.
Global change cooperation like again,
the example of Congo that I mentioned or like the,
forget that killing of that Guy Khashoggi it's horrible,
but the true nightmare is Yemen today.
What I mean you said somewhere that we should well think without engaging in
large scale reform what the consequences will be if you,
okay.
Very briefly,
I agree with you that the gap of standard mark season was the proletarian
revolution will be a place where you do something and you know exactly what you
do.
If there is a lesson of the 20th century is that this tragic logic you want
something may be good.
The result is catastrophic Holt,
absolutely.
Also for revolutions and so on and so on.
But uh,
but like,
uh,
in spite of all this and I don't know what form will it have,
I'm not pleading for a new land in his party or whatever and just pleading for
new forums of international cooperation and Shawan I agree with you when you
said the majority of us is not even really aware of the seriousness of
especially the pool of ecological problems and Lavonne and I think,
would you agree that [inaudible] much more supple and Aquin?
Uh,
we,
it's logic that in [inaudible] is called the survival.
Caroline ignored in frank [inaudible] a BM MECO men we know ecological problems,
but we don't really take them seriously.
And here I see problems and I don't see an easy way,
oh,
are you,
I am affecting me.
If you asked me when people say no,
but they are growing,
protests are growing and so on and so on.
Yes.
I'm listening to this story from when I was young.
You know,
they are grown.
And then look what happened.
The mega tragedy is for me for a jumper.
What happened to Teresa?
They were elected for clean,
keep,
whatever.
And they become,
and I'm not blaming them,
they become the perfect executors of,
uh,
of austerity program.
So I just see problems.
I am a pessimist and I'm not a radical pessimists,
but you have to maybe here we are different.
I noticed with your final speech,
that final moment of your invention that it's very strange because usually mark,
she's kept this stupid optimist entrepot locally.
Just get rid of capitalism.
[inaudible] all be happy.
My God,
and much more a passion.
I don't believe in human goodness.
I beat never under estimate,
uh,
evil.
Never under estimate envy.
I mean,
it's part of my nature.
In Levenia we hear [inaudible] story,
uh,
a godlike figure comes to a farmer and I will stop immediately and ask and ask
him.
I will do to you,
do you whatever you want.
Just I want a new IB.
Do twice the same to your neighbor.
You know what Levine farmer answer Tine.
Take one of my eyes.
You know,
we are indeed.
Don't underestimate this.
I don't see any simple clear way out.
You're [inaudible]
thank you both very much.
It's pretty clear I think to all of us that you both have quite a bit to say to
each other and so and through ourselves on and,
and so I think before we jumped to some audience questions,
I thought it would be nice to give each of you a chance to ask a response or ask
a question or two from each other.
So starting with you,
Dr. Peterson,
maybe you want Kimberly to wasn't fair to well I've only to do your reply.
I like three questions
in two of them are now completely irrelevant.
And so,
um,
I have one left,
I guess.
And I'm not sure that it's a fair question,
but maybe it's seems to me to be a fair question.
You're a,
you're a strange marks as to have a discussion with and well,
but here's why.
This is not an insult by any stretch of the mind nation.
I mean,
one of the things that struck me when I was looking at your work was that your,
well first of all,
you're a character,
you know,
and that's,
that's,
that's an interesting thing.
Like you're decently,
it's a sign of,
it's a sign of originality,
Huh?
And,
and it's a sign of a certain amount of moral courage and,
and,
and it's a sign of a certain temperament and it makes you humorous and
charismatic and attractive.
And,
um,
and,
and I think you appeal to young people the way that outside intellectual rebels
appeal to young people.
And so those are all positive things that can be used positively or negatively.
And my question is like,
it seems to me that your,
your um,
your reputation,
unless I'm very misinformed about this,
is as a strong supporter of Marxist doctrines on the left or was that,
and so then my question is,
given the originality of your thought,
why,
why is it that you came to presume at some point in your life,
perhaps not now,
and perhaps steel,
that the promotion of Marxism rather say rather than disease that chasm was
appropriate?
Because it seems to me that there's enough originality in your body of thought
and lateral thinking in the manner in which you approach intellectual ideas,
that there's just no reason for you to be allied with a doctrine that's a 170
years old.
And that is if capitalism is rife with problems is twice as ripe as broad with
problems as that.
And so you're kind of a mystery to me in that way.
And so that's my question.
Okay.
All right.
Very briefly.
Alright.
Well I develop,
kicked him out typically in my book critical insights into many traditional mark
leash,
the leash.
So no doubt Pier,
you know what,
I still admire him nonetheless in March,
not though simplicities of communist manifesto,
but I still think that he show called critique of political economy capital and
Travon is a tremendous achievement as a description of the dynamics of
capitalist society in the fury.
Ditch mark is much more ambiguous and opened that,
for example,
he mentions for example a proport what you refer to.
He mentioned that law of diminishing return,
like while white crisis will arrive necessarily poor,
are getting poorer,
but then he is honest enough to enumerate seven or eight counter tendencies and
if you read him closely you will see that precisely those tendencies prevailed
later or forget communist manifesto,
go to read his political analysis of unsurpassable 18 Bremer and so on of the
1848 revolution,
which are incredibly complex,
no traces,
traces of that class binary there,
there march deals with middle classes with crucial lumpenproletariat with the
ambiguous role of intellectuals and so on and Travon.
But basically what I was pleading for and I like to put it in paradoxical term,
was for a return of from Mark's back to Kegel,
I define myself more as like a yet why Hegel is conceived or Hegel is considered
a madman,
you know the guy absolute knowing and so on and summer.
No Kegel is much more modest and open.
The danger in Marxism is for me this tell logical structure we are at the zero
point but there is a unique chance of reversal into a new emancipated society
and so on.
And the danger here is that of self instrumentalization proletarian Communist
Party is an agent of history which knows the loss of history to put it follows
them and so on.
That's the catastrophe in Hegel.
Such a position is strictly prohibited in Kegel.
Whenever you act you are so you know you have to,
there is no position of this pure acting where you know what you are doing and
the result be beach will be.
So I'm this,
this would be,
this would be my main point.
So yes,
my,
my formula is kind of a,
ironically,
I know Hegel is the greatest idea list,
materialists reversal of marks by turning back to Hegel for Hegel,
Hegel assess in a part that people don't read.
Introduction to forward 30 to philosophy of,
right.
He says explicitly that the all of Minerva takes off in the evening when there
is dusk.
So philosophy can just grasp a social order when it's already in its philosophy,
cannot see into the future.
It's radical openness.
We need this openness today.
The tragedy today maybe we agree here is that we really don't have a basic,
how to,
they call it cognitive mapping.
I don't think we have here a clear insight into where we stand,
where we are moving and so on and so on.
So I'm much more against,
you surely have a pessimist.
Can I ask you now a question?
Let me get
and then you can ask me postcards.
So John,
well,
yeah,
I don't have any thing to quibble about with what you just said about,
um,
well no,
there's not even a,
but really it's that the,
even if the,
if what you said about Mark's is more sophisticated thought is true,
I think the unfortunate reality is that any support for Marxism
especially
directed towards those are who,
who are young is likely to be read as support for the most radical and
revolutionary proclivities.
And I would say that as they're outlined in a,
in the document that I described,
yeah.
Um,
in the communist manifesto and that they're of extraordinary danger.
And so it seems to me that by attempting to,
you know,
rescue the sheep,
you've been,
you've sort of invited the dragon into the house and that seems to me to be
dangerous and unfortunate
here.
I can assure you by asking you mind question because,
uh,
you know,
very naively you mentioned first,
do you really,
where did you find the data that I completely don't see it.
Okay,
let me begin by this.
You designate your under quotation marks.
I'm not characterizing and me or what you are fighting against as sometimes you
call it postmodern,
neo Marxism.
I know what you mean.
All of this from political correctness to these excesses of whatever spirit of
envy and so on and so on.
Do you think they are really,
where did you find this data?
I don't know them.
I would ask you here,
give me some names or whatever.
Where are the Marxists here?
I don't know anything.
I don't
show me any big name of political correctness.
I think they they fear like a good vampire,
a fear of garlic.
Any Disney,
Shanghai,
they are already the one who is not a matter kids but at least approaches
economic Bernie Sanders,
he's already under attack is white male and all that stuff and Travon I him I
him plea by probably would be be Dishman what you describe as postmodern neo
Marxism,
where is really the market element in it?
They are for equality,
sorry.
Where they are for equality at these sculptures struggles or proper names.
How do we call the trigger?
Do you see in them in political correctness and Travon any genuine will have to
change society.
I don't see,
I think it's a heifer moralization typer moralization which is silent admission
of a defeat.
That's my problem.
Why do you call?
Give me no,
it's,
again,
it's not a rhetorical question for politely saying you are an idiot.
You don't know what you're talking about.
It's simply I would like to know because you and I like this often when you
attack somebody,
you said aggressively and my truth read more.
Tell me whom.
So I'm asking you now know there is more,
I don't advise you,
but who are,
give me some names and so on.
And who are this post?
Modern Egalitarian,
neo Marxist.
And where do you see any kind even of Marxism?
I see enough mostly and impotent and utterly impotent.
Moralization
please.
I'm so sorry to tell us.
No,
that's,
that's no problem.
Well,
I mean,
um,
organization like Jonathan Heights,
what's it called?
Heterodox Academy and other organizations like that have documented an absolute
dearth of conservative voices in the social sciences and the humanities,
and about 25% according to the what I think are reliable surveys,
approximately 25% of social scientists in the u s identified themselves as
Marxists.
And so there's that.
Well,
okay,
but
the,
I know a capital of Mark's list,
for example,
that's very Charlotte economic work,
which I don't totally Davey Tavey one,
but he ride very serious book of Economic Analysis and kill one in Taiwan.
Then there is the old guy who is far from complete fication,
Frederick drained Sean and Sean,
but they are totally marginalized today in this politically correct mainstream.
You know,
I don't see,
well,
yeah,
your questions seem to me to focus more on the PR,
the peculiar relationship that I've noticed and that people have disputed
between postmodernism and neo Marxism.
And I see the connection between the postmodernist types and the Marxist as a
sleight of hand.
That replaced notion of the oppression of the proletariat by the bourgeoisie as
the oppression by one identity group by another.
Totally agree.
Okay.
So,
but that,
but so now look,
we could,
we could precisely a non a non [inaudible] fellow that that's the seat that I
guess that's where we might have a dispute because I think what happened,
especially in France in the 1960s,
is as the,
as the radical Marxist postmodern types like Dera Down Fuko realized that they
were losing the moral battle,
especially after the information came out of the Soviet Union in the manner that
it came out that the nation.
And so yeah,
that the whole bloody is telling us,
yeah.
The whole Stellan this catastrophe along with the entire mouse catastrophe that
they didn't really have a leg to stand on.
And instead of revising their notion that human history,
and this is a Marxist notion,
should be regarded as,
uh,
the eternal class struggle between the economically deprived and the oppressors.
They just recast it and said,
well,
it's not based on economics.
It's based on identity,
but it still fundamentally oppressor against oppressed.
And to me that meant that they smuggled the,
the,
the fundamental narrative of Marxism and many of its goals back into the
argument without ever admitting that they did.
So now I've been criticized,
you know,
for this position because people who are postmodernists say,
look,
one of the hallmarks of postmodernism is skepticism of Meta narratives.
It's like I know that perfectly well and I also know that Mark's is as
[inaudible] is a Meta narrative and so you shouldn't be able to be a
postmodernist and a Marxist.
But I still see the union of those two things in the insistence that the best,
the appropriate way to look at the view world is to view it as the battleground
between groups defined by a particular group,
identity between individuals defined by a particular group identity so that the
group identity becomes paramount.
And then the proper reading is always oppressor versus oppressed with the
secondary insistence.
That's very similar to Marx's insistence upon the,
um,
moral superiority of the proletariat that the oppressors are by definition
because they're all pressed morally superior.
And,
and there's the call for
perhaps not revolutionary change,
although that comes up above,
but change in the structure so that that oppression disappears so that a certain
form of equality comes about.
Now you argued that Mark's wasn't a believer in equality of outcome and I'm not
so sure about that because his notion of the eventual utopia that would
constitute genuine communism was a place where all class divisions were
eradicated.
When,
so there's,
well,
well there's at an implication that the most important of the hierarchies had
disappeared.
And so maybe he had enough sophistication to talk about other forms of
hierarchies.
But if,
if that's the case,
then I can't imagine why he thought that the utopia that would emerge as a
consequence of the elimination of economic hierarchies would be a utopia.
Because if there were other forms of hierarchies that still existed,
people would be just as contentious about them as they are now.
Like we have hierarchies of attractiveness,
for example,
that have nothing to do with economics or very little to do with economics.
And there's no shortage of contention around that or any other form of ability.
And so that's why I associate the social justice types who are basically
postmodernist with Mark's post there postmodernist with Marxism.
It's the insistence that you view the world through the narrative of Oh,
pressed versus oppressor.
And I think it's a catastrophe.
I think it's a catastrophe.
And you appear to think of,
yeah,
well that's one sentence and then you can reply.
It's so funny that you mentioned,
for example,
somebody like
Fuko who,
uh,
for me,
I don't know whether that his main target Mark Keaton okay for him represented
in he and he's,
he's gained was never a radical claims,
but indicates what I don't like in this,
what you call postmodern,
let's not call them mark please.
But revolutionary,
it's enjoying your own self marginalization.
The good thing is to be on the margin,
you know,
like not in the center and on and Travon it almost made me nostalgic for old
communist school at least had the honesty to say,
no,
we don't enjoy our market position.
We want to do something central power.
I find disgusting.
No wonder you don't get invited to lots of places yet.
You're now,
you're now a call for me embodies this logic of evolution and by revolution he
meant any social trend,
serious that small resistances and so on,
small marginal places of resistance and Travon and Travon.
So,
okay.
But let's maybe drop it here if you want,
but kings,
you are replying to my question.
You should have
the last one up here.
I'll stop with that.
Let's move to the next,
we'll get back to these topics.
No doubt as we move forward with the question.
So I'm happy to let that,
that particular issue store,
did you already do your Stalinists manipulation and tens that the questions echo
because this program that she described to us through some screens,
scratches and Travon,
I think it booked scheme to the one who decides which questions are established
with foot in
the real voice of the people in,
hopefully we can trust him.
Let's move on from that,
uh,
hurt this evening.
Uh,
we're talking about happiness.
At least that's the frame of the debate that we have tonight.
And you've both been in your work and also tonight,
very critical of happiness as mere hedonism.
Pleasure seeking or even simply as a feeling,
what does true or deeper human happiness consist of and how is it obtained you?
I don't care.
Well,
I don't,
first of all,
there's something you said five minutes ago or so.
I think you were still at the podium that I agree with profoundly,
which is that happiness is a side effect.
It's,
it's not,
it's not a thing in itself.
It's something that comes upon you.
It's like an act of grace in some sense and my sense,
even the pure logical undertone of what not the category of grace can be used in
a perfect eight,
eight clench.
It loves the deepest.
Sorry.
Okay,
good.
Well,
I would think,
I would think that we can find agreement about that because partly because of
your psychoanalytic background,
you know perfectly well that were subject to forces within us that aren't of our
voluntary control and certainly happiness is one of those because you cannot
will yourself to be happy.
You might be able to will yourself to be unhappy,
but you can't will yourself to be happy.
There are certain preconditions that have to be met that are quite mysterious in
order for you to be happy and then it happens and then maybe if you're wise you,
you regard that as as a like an a minor in comprehensible miracle that somehow
you happen to be in the right place at the right time.
Now I've made the case that the most effective means of pursuing the good life,
which is not the same as pursuing happiness,
is to adopt something like a stance of maximal responsibility towards the
suffering and malevolence in the world and I think that that should be pursued
primarily as an individual responsibility.
It's not like I don't think that political and familial larger organizations are
necessary,
but in the final analysis we'd suffer alone in some fundamental sense and we
have our own malevolence to contend with in some fundamental sense and the
proper beginning of moral behavior,
which is that proper beginning of the right way to act in the world is to take
responsibility for that.
I think you do what you can to conceptualize the highest good that you can
conceptualize.
That's the first thing,
to develop a vision of what might be,
and it has to be a personalized vision as well as a universalized vision.
And then you work diligently to ensure that your actions are in keeping with
that.
And you allow yourself on that pursuit to be informed by the knowledge of your
ignorance and the necessity for acting and speaking in truth.
And a fair bit of that I believe is derived.
I think it's fair to say that that's derived from an underlying Judaeo Christian
ethic.
And I make no bones about the fact that I think of those stories,
um,
metaphysically or it philosophically or psychologically as fundamental to the
proper functioning of our society in so far as it can function properly.
And so it's not happiness.
It's meaning and meaning is to be found in the adoption of responsibility.
And then I'll close with this.
And responsibility is not only to do what you believe to be right,
that's not cause that's duty.
That's not enough.
That's sort of what the conservatives put forward as the ultimate virtue,
which is duty.
It's not that it's,
it's that you're,
you're acting in a manner that is in accordance with what you believe to be
right,
but you're doing it in a manner that simultaneously expands your ability to do
it,
which means that you cannot stay safely ensconced within the confines of your
current ethical beliefs.
You have to stand on the edge of what you know and encounter continually the
consequences of your ignorance to expand your domain of knowledge and ability so
that you're not only acting in an efficient manner,
but you're increasing the efficiency and productivity and meaningfulness of what
it is that you're engaged in.
And I think that,
and I believe that the psychological evidence supports this.
Even the neuropsychological evidence is that that's when true happiness descends
upon you because it's an indication from the deepest recesses of your psyche,
biologically instantiated,
that you're in the right place at the right time.
You're doing what you should be doing,
but you're doing it in a manner that expands your capacity to do even better
things in the future.
And,
and that's the,
I think that's the deepest human instinct there is.
It's not rational.
It's far deeper than that and it's something that it's something that's genuine
and that exists within us and that constitutes a proper guide if you don't
pervert it with just self deception and deceit.
So that's my first
[inaudible].
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll try if you're stupid enough to believe me to be brief.
Yeah.
Furnished.
I liked very much what you began with this
gray or whatever we call it,
moment of happiness.
And uh,
I would like to,
would you agree that the same goes for love?
I think we have a new dean in [inaudible] in France.
I don't know if he not their language.
Dicavid do you use the verb to fall in love,
which means it's in this sense,
in some sense of fall you or surprised you or shocked.
Authentic love.
I think it's something very traumatic.
Even in this sense.
I always like to use this example.
Let's say you leave a stupidly happy life,
maybe one night stand here and there.
You drink with friends,
then you fall in love passionately.
This is in some sense a catastrophe for your life.
All the balance is lost.
Yes.
So all,
you know,
so that's why it has arrows.
Sorry.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
So,
uh,
but uh,
when I first second,
surprisingly maybe for you,
I agree with your point about Judeo Christian legacy for which I am very much
attacked,
Eurocentric and so on and so on.
You know,
I wonder if you would agree with it.
I will try to condense it very much.
You know,
what's,
for me,
the deepest,
I simplify it to the utmost something unheard off and I as an eight A's accept
the spiritual value of it happens in Christianity,
in other religions.
You have got up there,
we fall from God,
and then we try to climb back through spiritual discipline in whatever training,
good deeds and so on and so on.
The former of Christianity is a totally different one is we philosophers would
have put it,
uh,
you don't climb to God.
God,
you are free in a Christian sense.
When you discover that the distance that separates you from God is inscribed
into God himself.
That's why I agree with those intelligent geologists like my favorite Gilbert
Keith Chesterton who said that this,
the cross,
the crucifixion is something absolutely unique because in that moment of alien,
the Llama,
Starbuck,
God father,
why have you abandoned me for a brief moment?
Symbolically got himself,
becomes an eighties in the sense of,
you know,
you get get there and that is something so absolutely unique.
It means that you are not simply separated from God.
Your separation from God is part of divinity itself and we can then put it also
in other terms,
maybe closer to you like that.
That's why for me,
happiness is not some blissful unity,
which highest value.
It's the very struggle,
the fall and so on.
And that's why I hope we both worry about what will this possibility of
so-called,
I'm horrified with it,
what Ray Kurzweil calls singularity and this blissful state I prefer not to know
about,
but the final point,
very brief,
uh,
what I only don't quite get.
Why do you put so much access to this?
We have to begin with the person with personal trainers.
I mean this is also the second tour.
[inaudible] I don't remember,
forgive me of your slogans in your book,
you know,
first set your house in order then,
but I have an extremely common sense,
naive question here,
but what if in trying to set your house in order,
you discover that your house in is in this order?
Precisely because the way the society is messed up with doesn't mean,
okay,
let's forget about my house.
But you can do both at the same time.
And I would even say I will give you now the ultimate example yourself,
isn't it?
That you are so socially active because you realize that it's not enough to tell
to your,
to your patients,
set your house in order.
March of the reason of why they are in disorder.
They're house is that there is some crisis in our society and so on and so on.
So my reproach to you benevolent would have been,
you know that joke.
Tea or coffee?
Yes,
please.
Like individual or social.
Yes please.
Because this is obvious in extreme situation like I hope we agree to say to
somebody in,
in North Korea,
set your house in order.
No,
but I think in some deeper sense it goes also for our societies.
I'm just repeating what you are telling you see some kind of associate crisis
and I don't see clearly why insist so much on this choice.
Because let's say just to finish,
I will give you an example that I think perfectly does it.
How do we usually deal with ecology by this false personalization?
You know,
they tell you,
ah,
what did you do?
Did you put all the coke cans on the side?
Did you recycle old paper?
And so yes we should do this.
But you know,
like I,
in a way,
this is also a very easy way to discharge yourself as like you say,
okay,
I do the recycling,
so up,
you know,
I did my duty,
let's go on.
So I would just say why the choice there?
Okay.
So,
well,
so first of all I have to point out that it's,
you have unfairly tasked me with three very difficult questions.
And so I'm,
I'm hoping that I can then slide,
as you said,
life is a challenge.
So I'm going to,
I'm that I have the
mental wherewithal to keep them in track and answer them in order.
But you can help me if I stray.
I was very interested in your comments about the,
about,
um,
Christ's atheism on,
on the cross,
that final moment of atheism that that's something I,
I'd never thought about it in that way.
[inaudible] [inaudible] no,
no,
it's a,
it's a very,
it's a very interesting thought because what it,
what it,
it's a really,
it's an unbelievably merciful idea in some sense that the burden of life is so
unbearable.
And you see in the Christian passion,
of course,
torture,
unfair judgment by society,
betrayal by friends and then,
and then,
uh,
low death.
And so that's,
that's kind of,
that's about as bad as it gets.
Right?
Which is why it's an architectural story,
right?
It's about as bad as it gets.
And the story that you describe points out that it's so bad that even God
himself might despair about the essential quality of being.
Yup.
Right,
right.
So and so that is merciful in some sense because it does say that there is
something that's built into the fabric of existence.
The tests are so severely in our faith about being itself that even got himself
falls prey to the temptation to doubt.
And if so,
that's okay.
Now
this is where things get very complicated because I want to use that in part
dance.
The other questions that you answered.
Yeah,
look,
there's,
there's a very large clinical literature that suggest that if you want to
develop optimal resilience,
and what you do is you lay out a pathway towards somewhere better,
someone comes in,
they have a problem,
you try to figure out what the problem is and then you try to figure out what
might constitute a solution.
And so you have something approximating a map,
right?
And it's a,
it's a tentative map of how to get from where things aren't so good to where
they're better.
And then you,
you have the person go out in the world and confront those things that they're
avoiding that are stopping them from moving towards that higher place.
And there's an archetypal reality to that.
It's you're in a fallen state,
you're attempting to redeem yourself and there's a process by which that has to
occur.
And that process involves voluntary confrontation with what you're afraid of
disgusted by an inclined to avoid.
And that works.
Every psychological school agrees upon that is that exposure therapy.
The psychoanalysts expose you to the tragedies of your past,
you know,
and and redeem you in that manner and the behaviorist expose you to the terrors
of the present and redeem you in that manner.
But there's a grip broad agreement across psychological schools that that's
that.
And my sense is that we're called upon as individuals precisely to do that in
our life,
is that we are faced by this unbearable reality that you made reference to when
you talked about the situation on the cross is that life itself is
fundamentally,
and this is a pessimism that we might share is fundamentally suffering and
malevolence.
But,
and this is I think where we differ.
I believe that the evidence suggests that the,
the,
the light that you discover in your life is proportionate to the amount of the
darkness that you're willing to forthrightly confront and that there's no
necessary upper limit to that.
So I think that the good that people are capable of his,
actually,
it's a higher good than the evil that people are capable of.
And believe me,
I do not say that lightly given what I knew about the evil that people are
capable of.
And I think that,
I believe that the central psychological message of the biblical Corpus
fundamentally is that that's why it,
it culminates in some sense with the idea that it's necessary to adopt.
It's,
it's necessary to confront the devil and to except your,
what would you say?
You're the unjustness of you're tortured mortality if you can do that and that,
and that's a,
it's a challenge as you just pointed out,
that that's sufficient to challenge even God himself,
that you have the,
you have the best chance of transcending it and living the kind of life that
will set your house in order and everyone's house in order.
At the same time.
And so I think that's even true in states like North Korea and like I'm not
asking people to foolishly immolate themselves for pointless reasons.
You know,
if I'm a,
when I'm working with people who are clinic clinically and they have a terrible
oppressor,
who's their boss at work,
I don't suggest that they march in and tell them exactly what they think of them
and end up on the street.
It's not helpful,
you know?
And so the pathway towards adopting individual responsibility happens to be a
very individual one.
But I do believe that the best bet for most people is to solve the problems that
be set them in their own lives,
the ethical problems that be set them that they know our problems and that they
can set themselves together well enough so that they can then become capable of
addressing larger scale problems without falling prey to some of the errors that
characterize,
let's say,
over optimistic and intellectually arrogant ideologues that I'll pose while you
have a let me close with one thing.
One of my favorite quotes from Carl Young,
it's actually a quote that I used at the beginning of my first book,
which was called maps of meaning,
was that if you take a personal problem seriously enough,
you will s Cymbalta obviously solve a social problem.
And this bears on,
on your point because it's not like you're a small family.
Even the relationship between you and your wife is immune in some sense to the
broader social problems around you.
And so let's say right now there's tremendous tension between men and women in
the West and that's certainly the case given the divorce rate,
let's say that would be some evidence.
Um,
and the later in later state ages that people are waiting to become,
uh,
to,
you know,
enter into permanent relationships.
There's a,
there's a real tension there.
And then if you do establish a relationship with a woman or a partner,
but we'll say a woman in this particular case,
um,
you are instantly faced with all of the sociological problems in a microcosm,
in that relationship.
And then if you work those damn problems out,
if you can work them out within your relationship,
then you can get some insight.
It's not complete insight,
but you can get some partial insight into what the problem actually is and get
the diagnosis right and you've moved some small measure forward in addressing
what might constitute the broader social concern and what's even better.
You're punished for your own goddamn mistakes.
And that's another thing I like about the idea of,
of working locally is that,
you know,
if I do broad scale social experiments and they fail,
it's like,
well,
tough luck for the people for whom they failed.
But if I'm experimenting on myself within the confines of my own relationship
and I make a mistake,
I'm going to feel the pain and then I,
and that's good.
That's just,
but it also gives me the possibility of learning.
And so I believe that you do solve what you can about yourself first before you
can set your family's straight and before you should dare to try to set the
world straight.
Otherwise you degenerate into this kind of,
you've already talked about it,
this shallow moralizing the this,
well,
I've divided my goddamn coke cans up and now I can spend more money on new
packaging at the supermarket,
which is exactly what the psychological research indicates that people do.
If they perform a casual moral action,
they immediately justify
committing a less moral action because they've put themselves in a higher moral
place and you might,
if you are a real pessimist,
you'd say,
well that's why they perform the action to begin with.
I think that's often true as associated with that shell or moralized
[inaudible]
again,
I've been putting my stallion [inaudible] uh,
what do you go at parish to say who needs the people?
We talk for the people and we know better than the paper.
No,
because I don't want,
don't want to take too much of the time for the public,
but you know what interests me.
Would you then agree because this is how Cagle rich,
the story of the fall that fall really is fairly cold pack in the sense that for
Hagle before the fall,
we are simply animals.
It's through the fall.
Did you perceive goodness s what?
We'll drag you out of the fall.
So in this sense fall if constitutive of the very,
you know,
it's not you fall from goodness you fall and that's that the electrical paradox,
your fault retroactively creates what you fell from as it were.
And that's the tough lesson for trip Miraleste to,
uh,
to,
to accept.
But,
uh,
you know,
where I see very briefly maybe a counter questions.
What fascinates me,
we didn't cover this,
I didn't cover this,
but speaking about ideology,
would you agree?
What fascinates me more and tomorrow is,
uh,
not Dick ideology in the sense of projects and so on.
In our cynical era,
people claim,
Oh,
we no longer take them seriously and swan,
but,
and here for me,
social dimensions enter entrust,
even our intimate space,
implicit beliefs,
it theological presu positions.
Why not,
which we embody in our most common daily practices.
For example,
probably some of you already know it.
I will nonetheless repeat a very shortened version.
I was occupied at some point by the structure of toilets in western Europe.
I notice this especially,
yeah.
Yes,
specificity of German toilets where you know the street doesn't,
she doesn't disappear in water.
It is,
they're exposed to that.
You smell it and control it for whatever.
And I immediately associated with German spirit of poetry and reflection and
it's a bad joke.
But what I'm saying is that in a sense,
and I've spoken with some specialists,
I was so intrigued by,
uh,
of how do construct toilets and they admitted it.
There is no direct,
a direct utilitarian reason.
It is as if even in something as vulgarus going to the toilet in theology in
this deeper sense.
Is there another thing that at the same level,
I repeat,
one of my old jokes that fascinates me intensely is how it's not just as
superficial psycho analyst claim.
We pretend to be moral to believe but deeply we are cynical egotists quite often
in today's times we think that we are free,
permissive and so on,
but secretly we are dominated by an entire pathological or not even often
pathological structure of prohibitionists and so on.
So we may,
and this is what interests me so much precisely in today's time where Dickies,
how would you agree?
We will explain the Hempel effect,
which may appear we are the cow apparently day,
so they tell us we live in,
but initially if times take your pleasure mate,
enjoy it.
But at the same time there is probably some clinicians are telling me more
frigidity and impotence than ever.
Yes.
The lesson of Pica and Leds,
I hope we agree,
is not this vulgar one.
You are cannot perform sexually.
You go to a site called the [inaudible],
he teaches you how to get rid of authority and Travon.
It's a much more complex situation.
It's a,
and this is what interests me immensely.
All this set of implicit belief SCO you don't even know,
but you,
you know,
I will repeat the story that half of you know.
And you my favorite,
that Neil's bar anecdote.
You know he had the house outside Copenhagen,
the quantum physics guy,
and he had a horse to a superstitious above each door.
Yes.
And then a friend asked him,
but do you believe you need,
why do heavy dead?
And he said,
of course,
no time.
The scientist why didn't do heavy dad,
because I was told it works.
The idea is it's prevent evil spirits.
I to enter the health.
It works.
Even if you don't believe me.
If theology today,
that's today fundamental.
Okay,
so,
so
[inaudible]
I'd want to solicit from you patellar Joe.
Don't you see that people,
I think,
I think that people are,
are possessed by ideas that aren't theirs there.
Yeah.
And their personalities that aren't there.
And that's the great psychoanalytic insight.
It's not ideas,
it's personalities.
It's way worse than,
than ideas.
And some of those personalities might be the ones that are Sodi associated with
the idea that freedom is found in maximizing hedonistic moment to moment
pleasure or something like that,
which sounds like freedom.
Like for me,
one of the things that I suggest to people is that they watch themselves as if
they do not understand who they are or what they're ruled by.
And then notice those times when they're there,
they're where they should be.
That,
and that's back to our discussion about meaning rather than happiness.
It's like you'll see there are times in your life where you're somewhere or
you've done something and all of a sudden you're,
you're together.
You're,
you're where you should be.
Your conscience is not disturbing you.
You're,
you're,
you're not proud of what you did because pride is the wrong term,
but you understand deeply you've done something that you should have done.
You might not understand why,
you might not even understand what it is,
but the study of that can help elucidate the difference between what actually
constitutes you is a very difficult thing to discover.
And what constitutes the accretion that characterizes you because of the,
well,
let's say you're intense.
You're intense proclivity for socialized mimicry.
And so,
you know,
you're,
I don't mean you personally,
but people are amalgams of everything they've seen and everything they've been
personally,
they've watched it.
Yeah.
And everything they've read.
And,
and to integrate that and define tha tha tha tha tha tha truth,
that constitutes,
that integration isn't incredibly difficult endeavor.
And one of the reasons why in 12 rules for life,
for example,
I suggested that,
oh,
try to tell the truth or at least don't lie,
is because one of the ways,
apart from pursuing what you,
what appears to you to be meaningful,
one of the ways of escaping from that possession by the kind of videology that
you're describing,
which is like it.
It's like a,
it's like an unconscious of unidentified axioms.
It's something like that.
Even though they take personified form,
they're like personalities is to stop saying things.
You know not to be true.
It's a nice pathway forward.
It's the original rule was tell the truth and I thought,
no,
that's not any good because you're so biased and limited and ignorant and
possess that you don't know what the truth is and so you can't be asked to tell
it,
but everyone does have the experience of being about to say or do something that
they know by their own.
They know as deeply as they can know anything about themselves that that outer
rinse or action is wrong and they still do it.
Now,
my suggestion is
try to stop doing that.
And one of the consequences while you can try and small ways like you might not
be able to manage it in big ways,
but now and then you know you're tempted to do something that you know to be
wrong and you could not do it.
And if you practice that you get better and better at not doing it and that
means you lie less and you and you take the easy route out lesson you pursue.
He dawn it,
pleasures that cost you in the future less.
You start to straighten yourself out,
you take the beam out of your eye,
that's essentially what you're doing.
And over time you have some modicum of hope that your vision will clear up and
you'll be able to see the proper pathway forward.
And that's part of the process of redemption.
And it seems to me to be in your grasp.
You're capable of doing that.
You have conscience,
it doesn't form you from time to time correctly about the difference between
good and evil.
The consequence,
the knowledge,
the consequence of the fold that you described,
which I think you described it very eloquent terms and that you can slowly make
your way back to the straight and narrow path that's characterized by maximal
meaning,
but also see the this instinct of meaning is a sophisticated one.
It's not that I'm making a case for the individual,
like Ayn rand makes a case for the individual.
That's not it.
I'm making a case for individual responsibility.
That's not the same thing.
It's like there is something that's good for you,
but it has to also be good for your family.
If it's just good for you,
that's not good enough,
and if it's good for you and your family and it's not good for society,
then that's not good enough either.
And so the responsibility is to find a pathway that balances these things in a
harmonious manner.
It's like,
uh,
I got a lot of this thinking from John Piaget and his idea of vehicle and
braided states,
right,
is you're,
you're attempting to find something like a game that everyone is willing to play
that can be played in an iterative manner and not degenerate.
Well,
hopefully actually ascend if that's possible,
hopefully become a better and better game across time.
And I do believe that.
I do believe that you can do that.
I do believe that you can do that if you're guided by truth.
And I do believe that the pathway to that is the phenomenology of meaning.
And then the secondary consequence of that is if you do that now and then you
might be happy and then you should be profoundly grateful because happiness as
we already agreed upon is something like a grace.
What basically,
sorry,
I gave,
okay,
my best and museum come here.
I agree with you.
But the danger here,
here he,
they all look,
he can massively enter,
you describe a nice situation you are attempt at or [inaudible] or whatever to
do something that you know it's wrong.
But
folk up totalitarian ideologies step in at this point and try to present to you
that the true greatness to do what you individually think it's wrong for the
higher costs.
You know who says this wonderfully,
Eh,
according bird guy,
not uh,
uh,
how many [inaudible] of s s no,
no,
no.
Sorry.
Seriously.
No,
he,
he knew the problem.
Yes.
German office setups must do horrible things.
Yes,
he'll do it.
And solution was Dabora first to let them know [inaudible] every EDL,
IDL,
okay,
ordinary men can do something great.
Maybe not all sacrifice himself for his country,
but his reply was,
his point was,
but it takes a truly great men to be ready to lose his soul and to do horrible
things for his country.
Yeah.
And I read some good memoirs of relatively honest communists who broke down when
they were sent to the countryside for me in early thirties.
And this is what,
this is what they were told by apparat chick.
You will see horrible things till and starving and Chavon.
Remember there is the higher costs and your highest ethical duty is to is to
overcome this small bourgeois sentimentality and so here I see the danger of
again my pessimism,
false meaning which can massively cover this false narrative.
Second thing also the solution by,
I wonder if you share this pessimism of mine,
another one by him let you know what was his sacred book I read,
he all the time had a special leather bound copy in his pocket.
Bhava got Gita,
he must've Lee.
He said he probably was at least one.
He puts it perfectly.
Nazi officers have to do assess horrible things.
How to enable them to do it without themselves becoming curable beings.
He solution was oriental wisdom to learn to act from distance.
I am not really there and this is was the sock of my life based on this.
Do you know the book?
I found a book.
The guidance wrote many books.
Brian,
Victoria Zen at war.
It's a shocking book,
especially horrible for many so-called enter Eurocentric who flame out of
monotheism is guilty of everything we need oriented.
Yeah.
But that book is about the,
apart from a couple of exceptions,
the behavior of Zen Buddhist community in Japan in the thirties early forties
not only,
they totally supported Japanese expansion into,
into China,
they even provide that properly.
Zen Buddhist justification for it.
For example,
the one,
you know who did this?
No,
you are not as old as me.
I remember him [inaudible] Suzuki the great pre,
yeah.
But okay,
he was doing this in the 60s but as a younger guy,
he was fully supporting Japanese militarism and one of his justifications was
this one,
the advice to have Japanese military to them to support Zen Buddhist training
because he says it's one of the most horrifying thing that I've ever read.
He said,
sorry,
don't take no personally.
But let's say an officer orders me.
If I were to take these two,
it would be too obvious.
So APQ I have to kill you or stab you with my,
and he says,
if I remain in this illusionary shelf,
then I feel responsible,
I kill you.
But he says,
if you are enlightened by Zen Buddhism,
then you know there is no substantial reality.
You become a neutral observer of your life,
just a flow of phenomena and you tell yourself,
it's not that I'm killing you,
but in the cosmic dance of phenomena,
my knife is floating and somehow your knife falls.
You know what I'm saying?
This,
I'm not disputing some spiritual greatness of Zen Buddhism.
I'm seeing how even the most enlightened,
the spiritual experience can set up a teddy bear costs now because we're running
very quickly out of time
and it's clear that this conversation could go for a very long time.
I'm going to ask one representative question here and I'll give you each one
minute each and that is,
and that is simply this coming from online.
What is one thing you hope people will leave this debate with and why?
Jordan,
I,
I hope they leave this debate with a belief in the power of communication
between people with different views.
No,
that's [inaudible]
I mean there,
there,
there is this,
there is a growing idea on college campuses.
Tell me if I go over my minute that there really is no such thing as free speech
because people are only the avatars of their group identity and they have
nothing unique to say.
And besides that there's no communication across boundaries of identity,
your belief.
And,
and I think that that's an unbelievably dangerous and pernicious,
um,
uh,
doctrine.
And I think that people of goodwill,
despite their differences can communicate and they can both come out of that
communication improved even though there might be some dissent and some,
some dissent and some dissent on the way.
And so that's what I would hope people would come out of that.
Right.
[inaudible]
it'd be model concrete.
Even politically there is today show,
it appears this big conflict between other debt both smarter and stop that you
oppose and this all trite and Shawan I hope can hear Lee debt we made at least
some people to think.
And to redirect this opposition there are quite reasonable.
The only alternative to all tonight is not a political correctness and so on.
And I know I'm speaking not for you but for me.
Please.
If you are a leftist,
don't feel obliged to be politically correct.
Don't be afraid.
Don't be afraid to be.
And uh,
thanks.
Thankfully.
Would you agree?
One great version of not thinking is how immediately if they don't agree with
you,
you are labeled a fascist.
But that's the laziness.
People find something,
they don't agree with it.
Instead of thinking they think about something,
we all agreed was the best thing up.
You are a fascist and so on.
You know it's not as simple as that.
Even Trump of whom I am deeply critical.
No,
I'm sorry to tell you.
Yes,
he's the catastrophe in the long term and so on,
but he is not a factory.
You make it all too easy to play these games.
I blushed one not a positive result,
but to shatter a little bit too to make you think.
I have always felt that the greatest conversations or unfinished ones,
please join me in thanking slash [inaudible]
in Jordan Peterson for a grade on finished conversation.
[inaudible].